welcome to this video coverage for a
tata steel 2014 round five yeah this
tournament is a bit different to the
Tata Steel tournament of former years
because they have two rounds played i'm
not mistaken it's two rounds not played
in my gonzi the your usual location they
have two games played out so in
Amsterdam and this means the tournament
is sort of moving around and this leads
to more rest days so we had a rest day
yesterday and yeah now more action on on
Friday the 17th let's check the games
and we have six games of course and to
be honest they're all interesting and
this means i have some problems with the
video tried all i need to admit it's the
best for the commentator to have one or
two really interesting games and for
snoozes so you can easily look at the
four less interesting ones and then
focus on two games and do them like for
real and this time it's a bit tricky
because they all have their points but
also none of them is like um yeah worth
pointing out so much that you should not
look at the other so I'll have a look at
a brief look at all the games but I
won't get into very very young minuscule
details ok let's go to Nakamura takkan
hard to predict an opening for this for
the Sun for this game now camera playing
default we have a classical nims oh okay
yeah kind of causes a long time muzu
Indian player so this could be predicted
and he went for d5 one of them
sharper replies to the classical sharper
because it immediately provokes a crisis
in the center opening it up a three the
cameras response and this means that
like has given up the bishop pair not
uncommon in the names oh but in as a
compensation he gets quick piece play 94
gaining a temple and now c5 making sure
the position of the center is really
opening up yeah why does not really have
a choice he needs to take this pawn and
now 96 we see that black has got two
nights and to play it has opened the
center while white has only moved the
Queen so this is a line were black put
some lots of emphasis on on quick piece
play the white really needs to make sure
that he's not mated quickly and he needs
to catch up in development he first
takes on d5 it's a bit difficult to to
manage without the booth for example if
white plays 93 which he can't play it's
not a bad move he needs to awaken
amongst others with Queen 85 after which
it some quite difficult to to keep any
life in the position for example after
Bishop t2 Quincy five this is the main
threat on f 2 so this is a typical line
where white has given up the bishop pair
his main asset and also does not have
any real prospect of an advantage cd5 is
the sharper move after 85 white goes III
also to control d4 and try to speed up
development of the King side it's the
sole line is a bit a bit risky for white
it is a decent theoretical reputation
I'm not saying it is bad but you need to
be very very technically aware and in
the wake that black is not just young
winning quickly with within with an
attack on the king castles 93 and Bishop
f5 this all very logical the night
threatening a big discovered attack so
why do plays Bishop d3 nothing too
surprising them check and queen air five
in fact them this position has been
played before and the next move on our
cameras I think a novelty at least if
you compare it to my database he played
kingi too in response to the check yeah
but in principle there are only two were
dangerous moves King it to and b4 b4 has
been tried before the idea being that
after night before which black
essentially must play a bee queen a1
this queen is bit off side and it can
lead to dangerous attacking play for
example after castles Queen f6 really
necessary otherwise the Queen's almost
wrapped Bishop b2 and then possible 94
White has some dangerous initiative for
the exchange but it is not really enough
to play for an advantage so King e2 I
mean white can't play a little move like
Bishop b2 but it's in fact at that
technical problem with this after ninety
to ninety to ninety oops night before
white cannot really make this work yeah
for King 92y can play it's better than
Bishop b2 but not a very attractive
yeah kidney to as an ambition stripe but
obviously the king is not really in
great shape in the center yeah kayak in
place normal centralizing moves rook e8
yeah rook d1 and the Bishop g4 this is
good setting up a pin and preparing the
coming sequence after before he is not
intending to take on before because
after night before a beam Queen takes
Bishop b2 green eight-oh bouquet one the
queen is unfortunately trapped he is not
planning on that but instead plays
Quincy 7 and this shows that Bishop g4
was setting up the spin to make sure
that the queen is actually attacking the
pawn on h2 and this is the real threat
if white plays nothing looks like we
should be two black will take that and
threaten to to win quickly a black is
winning in the game here no way to
defend against the tech what really
needs to play something like Age 3
youichi did she takes takes black plate
Knight to g5 and well this is quite
something this thread so white needs to
react plating Bishop to be too and now
black play d4 this is all very logical
attacking the King in the center and
opening up the position the queen is
always having this additional idea and
damn if you look at this position with
the help of a computer it turns out that
black some attack already is so strong
that white needs to be really really
cautious to not get run over quickly he
played the moves h4 now we see that the
time recording here on icc is a bit
sloppy a bit problematic acid chosen
negative clock time I think if i'm not
mistaken nakamura used really lots of
time here after age 4 to try to keep the
game going but it was um spent this time
without any success because after age
for black cam can basically end the game
with the combination to set up a
perpetual which she did it also seems if
you analyze it that black does not
really have a great option to avoid the
draw he could yeah me too also retreat
this night let's say to ease things but
chapter Bishop takes King some way and
push it back Blackie really does not
have enough compensation on let's say
probably no compensation for the
material is two parts down after all and
what kayaking did is just the
professional choice he went for the draw
if he does not see a concrete way
forward then a draw is okay check and
take here effect on e3 a fleshie move
that leads to a forcing sequence of
capturing Queen d2 King moves acting
edge one and it's just a perpetual check
there is no way to escape it white can
only go for ya funky check self-made
Slyke check checkmate like those um so
um it is a draw they can't a couple of
mortals check and then agree to a draw
yeah if you study this game with an
engine that will basically reproduce the
whole game and show that white was
playing the sharpest moves and like
replied with the most precise moves to
secure draw so quite logical games a
game in a way
this kind of line is always tricky to
play for y del doctor I don't really
like it so much to lose time in the
opening two to draw the such a big
attack on me I guess Nakamura wanted the
sharp fight and then got it but ki came
found exactly the precise way to to get
to equalise and draw the game alright so
the next game to check let's look at
kawana against from viele yeah come on
i'm playing 1.e4 and then various really
one of the guys who regularly plays the
sicilian always going going for a fight
in ya not symmetrical positions and
correct yeah are not a surprise but
koala goes for the open saline after 96
here there should be five nowadays is
really the most popular move but okay of
course d 4 is the most principled choice
and with fun video show you to get
washed it off they played them the the
modern main line of this rash Nick off
nowadays some whites mean try is exactly
what kawana is playing the old line or
let's say form a main line like this is
not played that often anymore it's
probably not bad at off white but it
seems that blacks resources are quite
adequate at the moment Bishop takes f6
is not so popular anymore but 95 and
this move water
followed by a seafoam is the most
popular now this very often leads to
positions where white has very very
slight pool it's not like a huge threat
to black some game but it's not so so
comfortable we see that after before
which is probably forced white just
retreat and sets up this information on
the King side the idea being that white
quickly can activate the bishop on f1
which to TGT speaking is not such a
great piece looking at the light squares
so this is something that makes sense
white wants to ideally exchange it on a
three and this is one thing that blacks
position at the moment legs it has this
Bishop on f6 which is not doing much and
which really would like to be activated
one way could be a bio g7 like g6 h5 and
then play it just like white is doing
going to g7 and to h6 and the other way
to activate the bishop would be y r-d 8b
6 all the way to deform or to see 5 or
this would be a dream scenario and not
easy to accomplish but something that
like and try to do the drawback from
White's perspective in this position is
the somewhat weak square default like
manages to sink a piece and now it will
be very nice okay let's see how it
continues some very place a 5 yeah this
was saying a logical move Bishop a
stream will be eight Queen d3 is all
quite quite normal looking and don't
know when very place a four
not sure that this is the most precise
move but okay suddenly a play will one
be three normal just stabilizing the
position but now the next move I don't
really like that and it seems like this
is already a form was a new move but the
next one I don't really like I think
that when vini now place this move a bit
prematurely it takes on d5 and i really
like it much more to to keep the tension
of it not one hundred percent sure what
move on black should take under should
play I understand that he may be was
worried about the capture like Knight
takes Queen takes Queen d6 but I'm not
sure that this really it was right after
Knight f6 there's even GTX of 6 in some
cases the computer likes to play rook e8
going back from be a 28 but it's at some
point I mean the a file is about to be
opened so look ahead it's not
necessarily bad yes mentally 21 d5 and
after see text e5 Knight a5 yeah it's a
bit of a problem you don't want the
night to be passive but where do you go
you can also go to e7 but there before
as a weakness and there's this idea that
can also put lots of pressure on black
the night only seven does not have a
great future as well where exactly as it
is it going yeah it on g6 it doesn't
have any squares as well then really
played 95 probably too
keep some pressure on b3 and be ready to
capture a night on c4 if it p.s castles
and Queen 38 covering the a four-point
93-yard logical to activate it should be
eight yeah planning the mansion to
regrouping but this is answered by night
f5 and why it always keeps this nagging
pressure in this position now attacking
the d6 bond-like covers and go into III
good news looking at the somewhat
unstable look and in some cases white
can also switch over to the King side
after g6 what has the funny reply Queen
h6 simply ignoring the threat to the
night because after the capture like I
didn't do that but after the capture you
should bear five this is simply
unavoidable the meydan h7 like has not
even a move to delay it this should have
six Andrew p1 by now b3 was for saying
so need to cover that the problem of
blacks position is that white has more
than one weakness that he can attack
there's d6 always under fire by the
night and another weakness is c6
whenever this night on a5 is moving then
c6 is a nice entry square for the rook
also the bishop on h3 is it's not really
pointing into thin air controlling c8 is
very useful
yeah black took and Queen back to the
aid covering this Bishop so that maybe
at some point blank can actually take so
why does playing whoopsie one of course
the right file and rook e8 still if like
would take we have this chocolates now
chat white check checkmate white meeting
so rupee eight and 93 so even night c4
under the right circumstances can be a
good idea now if white manages to
infiltrate and dominate on the C file
but of course you need to be be cautious
not to exchange too much visual yourself
and the Queen retreats yeah quick rate
is not really nice but blankets has got
nowhere really to avoid it where should
the Queen go taking would be especially
bad improving wide structure with the
age porn now in the meeting to black
falls so I'm not really good look to be
eight and now night see for white always
has this nagging edge he went to be
seven young I'm not sure about this oops
no this was unattended black cam can of
course take on c4 let's say something
like that the problem is there's always
this rook on c6 that you can absolutely
never take because whenever this happens
the C porn will win the game and this is
such an uncomfortable position to defend
I can really understand that when really
didn't want that you played as mention
I'd be seven maybe hoping to activate it
on c5 c5 is not a bad square for the
night of course but it's still not so
threatening as he formed taking the base
porneia Queen III
Bishop back yeah the bishop is covering
the d6 part so black can move the night
enter the Queen ok one try to invade c5
and now Knight e5 going all the way to
c6 the c6 weakness really is the big
point and yeah this CAPTCHA on d5 all
initiated this structure this is why I'm
a bit skeptical of taking their at this
particular moment yeah 92 a5 and white
invades on c6 and this night is also
attacking the vport before ball and it
turns out that this is really hard to
defend black can of course you can look
at them look like it will be six but is
it really helping if the white for
example takes on ahead place look-see
for attacking it like can try to play a
queen a 62 to defend oops rook takes and
Queen a to attending queen bee one check
and rook a one this kind of Defense this
is maybe what black must do is this
about the computer gifts but very
difficult to play like that you played
Queen to f6 and basically gave up the
pawn white does not take it immediately
you can first improve the pieces this
Bishop especially is very nicely placed
on c4 as it covers the only weakness and
also has some active role covering
important squares and being potentially
ready to being used on this diagonal if
the deep whenever
captures on c6 yeah Kim to h2 and white
slowly but certainly improves the
position yah g5 has a very weakening
move but the sit and wait strategy
probably wouldn't have paid off anyway
you can never save the B pawn and if you
don't do anything actively you'll
probably lose in the long run Tex and
Queen f3 attacking f7 in the process and
now gaining the pawn yeah after that
fantini really resists for a long time
checked it seems that white is having
simply too too big of an edge it's a
probably not savable he managed to
exchange some pieces but this is not a
simple opposite colored bishops position
because we have two rooks on the board
and blacks structures also slightly weak
with g for this is why black also played
f5 if white has got enough time you will
easily win the Jeep on and here he tries
with active play but at the end why does
to active himself now the rook enters on
the six and it's still a pretty tough
defense but at the end like he is not
able to hold this Y can improve chanting
further and with more pawns yeah here
black has managed to gain the g3 porn
but white in the meantime has three
passes himself and this is too much even
the opposite colored bishops endgame
here the pure opposite color bishops and
game is the winning for white because
the points that are relevant are so far
split and far away from each other that
it's not possible to construct a
fortress type
why just pushes and to here to make any
progress you need to get the g porn so
why just promotes and gives it up to get
the Jeep or net here can't it's it's
really a simple win like now resigned
white can simply go all the way to c6
and promote the beep on black has no way
to to fight that if two points with
opposite color bishops are spread apart
far enough B&G parness really really
comfortable wide simply promotes one of
the pawns and wins the endgame so nice
win form Caruana against fan valley i'm
not really one hundred percent sure
where black made the decisive mistake
i'm not i'm not positive that you can
pinpoint do one or two single moves i'm
pretty sure that this is not a correctly
time move because right after that
really am obtains a very one-sided
position where you can try for ages and
hardly ever lose it so this is maybe a
questionable decision but it still does
not feel that like necessarily needs to
lose the game he probably had some more
tenacious defense but I didn't really
didn't really find it alright so let's
go to the next game um Wesley so against
Boris Gelfand the number one offer the
Philippines again the former World
Championship challenger from Israel and
here i think girlfriend got into some
trouble because it played the only one
or two slightly inaccurate moves but
this really led to the big problems we
see what what happened so it's not
playing deform the open the so yet we
would have gotten especially coffee a
small girl font being one of the
top guys playing those reznikoff okay we
have e 5 blocking the d4 break for ya
forever basically the the problem is if
you are aiming for especially cough you
basically need to play Knight f6 or e6
but 906 white can also besides d4 on so
it's Bishop b5 and we have an entirely
different type of position here we have
Russell limo with those two nite moves
inserted which is really a bit special
for example after Knight d4 white has
got the interesting with e 5 with very
sharp blame ya it means that black has
this option of avoiding the open
Sicilian all together and it's a line
that usually leads to quite static play
the center's open closed closed and only
with sometimes quite complicated
maneuvers you can improve your position
so very normal luthien ya 92 is not it's
also normal move but some rules that
probably need some explanation Black has
weakened the d5 square obviously he
played pawns on 75 and white uses his
pieces to control d5 the bishop and
Nyjah do a good job doing that but white
an addition wants to use the f3 knight
to control d5 and this is why he plays
92 the first move of this typical night
maneuver d 6 and 9 f 1 and now Bishop to
g4 this is um yeah an interesting move
just attacking the Queen and provoking
some kind of reaction that this properly
without its drawbacks f3 the norm but
not a movie Oh welcome too much
weakening the dark squares it seems that
was Lisa wanted to avoid that so I
played Queen d2 which looks really a bit
strange but at the moment the bishop on
c1 wasn't really intending to be
developed so quickly anyway so it's not
a big issue and white will gain some
time with 93 coming on this bishop so on
it's a strange-looking move but not bad
at all yeah very normal move c3 securing
some oops I don't like that securing a
square for the bishop of puzzle wife
necessary and controlling the d4 square
black played Bishop u6 it wasn't really
doing much on g4 anymore and white this
also stepping to the side to a lower
later development of the Bishop Knight
b6 straight and a4 like head b5 as an
idea someone stops that I'm guard King
h8 very normal move of black ever
intends to play the f-bomb this is a
useful one should be too it's quite
interesting to see that he's never
playing 93 at this concrete stage
because probably Bishop g5 is an easy
equalizer activating the bishop and
getting rid of it in in most cases which
makes sense if you look at the fact that
this is a dark squared Bishop and like
has so many pawns on dark square Bishop
b2 is so smooth black still could have
played Bishop g5 it's not
terribly bad but he didn't do that he
played the Queen 37 not bad at all root
d 1 and d 5 so black finally placed this
free move after why trillium didn't show
much interest in blocking the square so
draining and 93 yeah here's an important
point black cam must avoid a move that
might appeal to some players because it
um yeah this is such a simple solution
on black plate we should be six the best
move you must be aware that Bishop takes
c4 is not a good idea and this is
because of this recapture very important
thing to notice the automatic recapture
with the night is really leading to
nothing it's not bad because it attacks
two important points but black can
relatively simply cover that the
recapture with the bone however is much
more dangerous because it establishes a
great square on d5 for man I'd wet
cannot easily be expelled the knight on
d5 also a text the important b6 weakness
so taking on c4 really as a positional
mistake so black retweeted and queen bee
three pressure rising this weekend pawn
and also pressurizing this bishop yeah
now I'm galfond goes for an interesting
transformation he took on these three
means that you can't even easily miss
because it's did we had to take this
come upon but of course it's working due
to the pins yeah white responded with
the capture only six and on b6 this is
quite logical yeah and I think right now
um Jack Gelfond could improve but he
even he didn't didn't go for for the
move Oh in fact I'm sorry I confused my
my nodes as one moves later he played
Queenie for ok and now b3 and exactly
now it's the point where I think he he
should improve he played rupee 8 which
is it seems far too passive he had a
good solution here with the move c4 and
this would have helped black enormously
it frees this Bishop which is not
threatening at the moment to go to c5
but in general it opens up this diagonal
and it introduces a very nice tactical
idea if white plays before the normal
looking move Black has a very strong
technical point you can take on before
uh-huh she takes before and then take on
f2 this is really a bit a bit surprising
that this very violent solution is
actually possible after King takes rook
a check check can you won the s90 for
and black or threatening night c 2 with
a ton of checks and this is not all of
it that's also the sneaky move Queen d3
and Queenie to mate so wyd really needs
to react you cannot play a slow move
like Roxy one out the queen bee three
it's over so I'm the move before in
response to see files even a bit
questionable but what should why do when
you cannot take with the night of this
video to the pin so you probably only
have the capture on c4p takes e4 and
here like has a choice you can even just
take a form and have a have a decent
game this double porn is not really
helping white much you need to compare
this to the game in the game let's have
get that black played this relatively
passive move and now after castles and a
five-night c4 we see that the night has
a dominant position on c4 with this pawn
sacrifice c5c for black guy would have
made sure that the pawn appears on c4
and the bishop is activated now we have
a position where black is terribly
passive is always tied to the defense of
weaknesses b7c five e65 there all week
and white dominates with this eternal
light on c4 and the very sound porn
structure in fact this position collab
collapses really quickly Quincy to look
see one just expelling the Queen gap
this didn't really help much and now
white enters threatening this week palm
and b7 and if this falls the position
simply falls to pieces rook f8 and now
in a cool move look everyone just making
sure that this weakness the only
slightly weak spot is covered not such
an easy move to find and but you can get
to it if you check the line rook takes
b7 rook takes p7 queen bee seven Bishop
g5 this is what you might calculate its
in fact also good for white but this is
the kind of line that makes you play
move like rook f1 where you think okay I
can win with the material on the
queenside alone it just protect my only
weakness here what at least needs to
avoid the capture as this isn't made it
to ya as mentioned he played rook f1
prophylactic move to cover the only
weakness and after that Gelfond actually
resigned the game he's absolutely it's
got no move to cover hook takes b7 and
this means that
the whole position collapses the hip
aunt wins the game yeah not a great day
for golf and was having a rough
tournament he didn't really score
anything and in this event yet and here
again is officer quite quite drastic
loss not in the best of shape it seems
all right let's get to the to the next
game that will be far longer video then
had imagined as usual okay let's go to
report against Domingues here the the
real point of the game is coming coming
early or not the report that say that
the yeah the funny the funny part of it
is right here only three you know that
report is building a building in
reputation of being in highly original
play in the opening and here we go he's
really playing G form on mu 3 which is
frankly speaking of that I absolutely
never ever saw being played but well I
cannot really recommend to play it
combining the English and and gropes
opening but it's it's interesting and
leading to creative play we see quite
quickly after Bishop g7 5296 d3d 6 this
is hanging why does it one thing and we
see one point of this Jeep on push
compared to the usual fianchetto with g3
this yeah extended very extended
fianchetto has one point it obviously
controls the squares f6 and h6 so the
Black Knight cannot easily develop and
like needs to invest more time to get to
get this piece out the only general
issue of pushing your bonds like this is
of core
long-term King safety and we see that
this gets to be a problem quickly ecigs
displayed in tending 97 and now we've
seen an additional point of whites game
report now after h4 h5 takes on c6 which
also looks a bit a bit crazy if you're
not familiar with the English opening
but it's not so terrible moved because
it really weakens black structure and
introduces some interesting strategical
plain plate f4 now intending 93 and if
white really is given time you can set
up a really strong position Knight f3
efore Bishop e3 queen e to F to putting
some pressure on c5 just building up a
big space advantage so this is not
without its points black and must be
quick em auntie played a quick opening
of the position with e5 and here we
begin to see that King safety is an
issue where is the skin going to to be
safe in this game you can try long
castles but if you look at this now why
do I took only five this is also
probably the best move Bishop takes long
castles is also castling right into this
bishop and well do you want to Castle
short this looks crazy 93g and Bishop
takes this is funny black is also good
taking on c3 but he's saving time takes
and 97 to perform castles and 92 in fact
around here well let's say here after d5
the computer mafia is in fact short
castles but this is a move that a
computer can play well I can suggest
very let's say lightheartedly but
playing that
as a human players another matter the
king is wide open even if there is no
direct attack or refutation it does not
feel very healthy he decided to stay in
the center for the time being and
developed the Queen Bishop g4 o gauge to
rookie 827 yeah and around here it it's
clear that White's king is never going
to have an easy life here plate after
Luke f2 Queenie 6 plate the move Knight
to be three which looks completely
logical attacking the weak form but in
fact it proves to be the decisive
mistake as black knives a very good
direct solution if you want to treat
this as a little calculation exercise
you can pause the video and try to
calculate Lex good reply now alright I'm
going to show it black can actually take
on e2 and this is what he did despite
the fact that the loop is covering it's
a move that you can can miss because it
looks a bit strange to just capture the
calves upon but after group takes to not
even plate root xe2 like has the goof
Queen g4 and this is a very nice
multifunctional move attacking the
bishop the porn with check and also very
important threatening Queen g1 check
picking up the long look this is what
makes the difference after night b3 the
rook is unprotected and yeah White's try
to fight with not taking what's moving
the king but the King position is just
too shaking and yeah well this is the
thing that if you play a highly creative
moves like g4 and later f4 and so on its
aggressive it poses blacks poses
problems for black but it is also just a
risky choice your own king is not
finding a safe place anymore don't like
just I've got far too much attack e.m
yeah this is a bit you have to a
desperation move black and just get his
own attack going work takes III
accelerates it enormously yeah p 8 and
now the queen joining in and this is
already really completely winning for
black the discover checks are threatened
and queen III is also a big threat we
have a couple of more moves and spy
checks but after this sequence white
runs out of moves to set any problems he
played rugby 8 and the artificial takes
d3 King takes Queenie to King d for
black wins this a bit strange he
resigned before the mate was played on
this shiny or that matter t3 it's a bit
nicer in my book but just not not
relevant black was winning by a
checkmate fittingly because of white
ignoring the King position for the whole
game or let's say most of it yeah report
is a highly original player but it can
really blow up in your face if things
are not coordinated perfectly so pretty
drastic loss at the ends of domingues
alright so next game let's go to hurry
Krishna against give me how Krishna
opening efore and we get an Italian game
with the Bishop c5 and just like it is
fashion nowadays hi Krishna is playing
the solid line with c3 d3h 3 and so on
sort of slow a slow game and in the
Italian and nothing that black has too
terribly afraid of but a line that white
can certainly play to delay the game
right into the the middle game and keep
pieces on we have a couple of really
normal looking news there should be
three quite early but this trade is of
course common feature in any form v5
openings yeah black like took it do that
and continue to initiate the usual play
on the queenside yeah well flex play on
the queenside is quite stand what is
white going to do white has some addys
with the FR of course this is one reason
by your play Bishop e3 to initiate the
straight opening up the FR and you can
also try to on yeah concentrate your
pieces on the Kings side for some attack
we see a pretty standard build up now
black on the queenside and white
transferring his forces to the kingside
some repetition but white does not want
to draw immediately place Queen h2
understandably and after 27 f 2 and so
on is going for g4 yeah this is what I'm
was referring to white concentrating his
pieces on the King side but black has a
very solid defensive set up him take
some precautions now night back avoiding
nine th for for example out Queen g3 he
also played g6
I move to make sure that nothing
terrible is lending or third f5 can
always take it yeah the question is how
to proceed now White has sort of
improved some of his pieces though the
rooks and the queen is not badly placed
but how do you actually make some sort
of headway in this position he went for
the idea nie Dage form and Knight a5
after all it that turns out to be not
leading to much maybe something like an
immediate deform was more to the point
I'm to be honest I'm not so sure where
white gain White's game mum is really
getting getting problematic we see that
after a couple of moves he needs to be
really precise night edge form and c4d
for logical yeah don't want to have your
pawn structure wrecked by a long black
to take and now before we see that black
now has an instant idea of playing be
three or taking and going for rugby to
both ways counter play dumb this is some
i don't i don't really like it for why
to be honest blacks play seems easier
after Knight f3 oops Knight f3 black
went ahead with b3 takes takes the first
look strange why to block the beefer
where the rook is playing but it makes
some sense because it forces exactly the
straight and getting rid of those bishop
is an accomplishment because the night
on a five that has a nice square on c4
and here we get to the phase of the game
where precision is really paramount it
seems that
very quickly white gets into some
trouble he took on e5 which was answered
by night C for a good move the intention
being that after 86 black can recapture
with the night here around him we get
white loses the threat he plays Queenie
52 exchange wins that actually happened
and now 95 rook age 2 rupee 7 getting
out of this possible possible fork and
now white went 96 here it also was
possible to play night h 2 f 3 which I
really like getting this night on h4 to
play after 94 one can centralize with
nine to deform and yeah I it's already
slightly prefer black iam but this still
seems very very solid in the game you
play tonight to c6 and after night c4 it
became apparent that this double threat
it's not so easy to meet white needs to
set up him his pieces in a quite passive
manner now he has counter-attacked on b3
and of course black must must must see
active now white can never take because
of that played here this introduces a
new idea yeah the night on c4 I said too
terribly terribly place the for whites
defense it's just a very strong piece
and so note that there's still this
weakness the white is just falling apart
now it could could have defended
slightly slightly more
Nation see probably but it probably
would not influence the result this is
just to actor and 92 yeah what is blacks
plan still keeping the pressure on b2
and e4 it now takes a slide regrouping
the night retreats all the way to a six
this is the the best square let's say
the best square of the conservative ones
right in black skin yeah it blocks the
spawn and controls many very very useful
squares and of course black at the long
run will simply invade on the
second-ranked exactly that happened one
room to see two and the ideas to to play
work T to hear however gear yet another
idea can also just just take on on be
too but this was very strong attacking
the rook and after the capture is just a
deadly pin here here here this was the
reply check in after this it's a fairly
simple technical task with the great be
poor Lester as the trump card actually a
couple of moves we actually transpose
into a rook endgame but the well-known
line that drew can't games are always
strong does not does not apply here
check we see that
black and shift his attention to the e5
pawn he gave up on the vporn because it
could not be promoted but here he
manages to win the e5 pawn basketballs
like that and this is in fact a
relatively easy winning or easily
winning rook endgame because of the
weakness on g4 and blacks idea to play a
5-2 to open it up a couple of inches
yeah very precise play black was just
simply winning by picking up the h-bomb
like in the game trading books leading
to a winning king and porn and game yeah
it's not so easy in this game for me at
least to pinpoint White's decisive
mistake around here he probably
committed the decisive inaccuracies but
it's not not very easy to find out what
went wrong down he probably needs to
avoid at all costs that the Black Knight
here on d6 is showing up on c4 am the
square she probably must avoid like the
plague in the game it was terribly
difficult to play against this night so
Goodwin form Geary here with black
against harikrishna right so the final
game for this video is knighted against
aronia and here we have Berlin defense
it's not one of those opening that
really sends shivers down your spine
it's a it's a very good practical weapon
for black and I really understand that
it is played regularly but it does not
make for some exciting
Chas quite often let's see what happens
we have this main line but after night
2d 69 it just now not steering the game
towards the no end game like this but it
goes for details e5 which it first looks
completely bonkers because what about
the bishop ok black takes it but now
White has the funny move a4ai taking the
night which is an extra night at the
moment but this also does not have a
square so black loses this denied back
you played 9 24 9 txt form and now the
most d6 and this is a sign that black is
actually trying to play a more fighting
game then with other moves black also
could take here and play d5 this is a
well-known continuation that after eat
XD 626 screeches aah chak Queen e6 Queen
D for Queen d6 and so on check in dozens
of games already led to a draw in fact
this is very hard for black to to avoid
after you have taken on d4 and played
played d5 so on for practical reasons
it's quite important that black has
alternatives here in the game as
mentioned earlier played d6 there was
also the most d5 leading to interesting
play Black is allowing a possible
capture 16 but this mostly would improve
the spawn structure so it's not worried
about that too much d5 it's a bit
different but in general this move is
designed to open up the position for the
two bishops you only need to be cautious
that you're not quickly mated on the
or something like that but it seems to
be a solid set up to see that knowledge
did not really get to get to get
anywhere to Gandhi six chat gave this
check now you went for the end game
takes and Doug Bishop e3 yeah this is
some quite obviously very safe choice
for white he's got good positions for
his pieces Bishop on e3 is a nice the
anchor and black has got somewhat
wrecked pawn structure but of course
blacks got the two bishops which is a
very important factor and we see that
after many more news we get a
transposition to an opposite colored
bishops ending however both sides have
rooks this is important if the rooks
were often this position we can actually
and this smooth the capture if the rooks
were often this position you could get
simply agreed to a draw because there's
absolutely nothing ever happening with
roofs on there are some possibilities to
to continue the game and then find and
we see that in fact after a while it it
gets a bit more complicated than you can
imagine at this current position on the
board so let's continue yeah in fact
them how to assess the position I think
it's really dead equal very hard to
imagine that it's it's not going to be a
draw but yeah we see that it gets
complicated later at first you might
think okay why it is the one having a
passed pawn but you can never ever
get to get anywhere near the promotion
square quickly so it's probably really
draw let's put some more moves on the
board black managed to get the King
active invaded all the way to c4 so
let's clear that after rube trade it
would be completely dead so this is
where the fried lice some more moves and
still it's it's completely equal only
later shall get to the point where they
are interesting positions here for
example there's a little check white can
not take care of course k because of
roof g6 picking up the bishop so I went
here and now black took yeah not a big
deal Chad can easily regain the pony on
f4 but in the process he allowed the
seaport they become a passer so nothing
terrible happened but black now at least
has some hope to do something with the
CFC born a couple of moves later yeah
play has sharpened enormously and ponds
are very fired once a couple of moves
later we get to the first interesting
tactical sequences here y term could go
for an interesting line hmm I'm sorry I
read my notes wrong the line is a couple
of hooves later Bishop age six was
played this is good one of course
covering the promotion square but what i
was getting it at this is happening
later i'm sorry bishop c6 took g5 roop
t6 this is all ok
and here kappa lucas later look c 6-r
not very attractive this move shutting
in the bishop but this is not the main
point of c2 born as the point black can
also try to to win the pond but here
this is a funny line coming up after
look at five which turns out to be um a
big mistake they are interesting
complications what why should probably
do is to play on Bishop f4 at least
after this move the computer didn't find
a direct win after Rudy form the second
to g5 this is not to create bishop it
seems that this is probably holding but
it's not so apparent at first why
neither just move rook air-five is a
mistake but we see that here aronian
could have gotten a really big edge now
but he didn't take the chance that right
move now would have been King to be too
and here we have some funny lines if
wide now tries to promote his pawn with
Rock'em to f8 there's an interesting
continuation group d 5 rube takes eight
Queen promotes can check King c3 and now
if white promotes to a queen which is
the only yeah moves that make a move
that it makes any sense like has the
cool continuation which takes HD x g5
technique win h1 mate this is a funny
funny mate where the two pawns in
combination with Queen and born on make
sure that the king is checkmated is
quite quite a funny motif it would even
work with the rook on each one would be
even more impressive but this is nice
also note that it's cool that those
pieces are not contributing to the
defense at all require quite a funny
line yeah King be too would have been
the right response he played rock d 7
but in in response now knowledge does
not find the right defense but this is
in fact very difficult to to play this
type of position it's pure calculation
you can easily miscalculate I mean if I
say it's difficult to play that means
that in theoretically speaking if you
look at it with the computer it all
looks very easy it says mmm move this is
that and 000 but to calculate all the
various complications in a game it's a
tiny different thing yeah you should
have played rukka 52 to put up more
resistance black is still fighting for
for the win more but it's this one
that's still fairly resilient look at
three are ever after King a 2 at the end
leads to like promoting the pawn it
takes a while first takes the SL gone it
takes a while but it's at the end
unavoidable he first uses all the parts
check then make sure the rook is is
playing and invading now here we go
Looby to King g7 and now rock d to the
final point to to win it intending rook
to d1 which at the end will promote the
sea porn so a nice end game when here
for Aronian who really didn't have much
during most of the game but in the
decisive part of the game that
calculation precise calculation was
unimportant he was just the more precise
and direct play i compared to tonight it
yeah a very eventful round
with five decisive games out of out of
six so some quite a huge huge part of
decisive games all right I hope you
enjoyed the coverage here for round five
i hope that i'm not mistaken in telling
you that drone 6 is coming tomorrow and
it's not forget another rest day and
let's hope form a similar simula
fighting round with lots of designs into
size of games like today yeah thanks for
watching till then I'm